Over the past few minutes, we've talked about how the sum of two cubes and the
difference of two cubes can be factored. And we learned earlier about how the
difference of two squares can be factored. Seems logically then like we should
also be able to factor the sum of two squares, something in the form a squared
plus b squared. What is the factored form of that though? Let's talk about this.
Earlier we saw a difference of two squares that was x squared minus 1. So let's
turn this into the sum of two squares instead, to see if that is something we
can factor. So let's consider x squared plus 1 instead of x squared minus 1. So
I'd like you to think through how we might factor x squared plus 1. And if you
can find a way to do it, check yes and write in the factors. And if you can't
find a way to do it, then check no.